فهمم
سنتمكن من التواصل
واستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا فقد شاهدنا ان
الروسيا قد عانت
خسائر جم في اوكرانيا بسبب
اااه
الجلود الاوكرانيين المدربين
ومهارتهم ويجب ان لا يد القرن روسيا ما
زال هناك المزيد من القوات يعملون على
الحصول على مخزون عسكريه ودخيره وهمم
يعانون وسيواصلون الحرب ولا يوجد اي مؤشر
بان الرئيس بوتن قد تغير من هذا فيه في
هذا الاستهداف
لاوكرانيا سنواصل دعمنا لاوكرانيا من جديد
مهمه جدا للرئيس السيد معي اننا نقف كلنا
متحدين
والاتحاد الاوروبي في دعمنا لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
سناخذ سؤال
ثاني
[موسيقى]
هل تفكرون بارسال دبابات
متقدمه ان تخشون ان هناك همم
خطوره لتصعيد
قلت من البدايه منذ
تصوير روسي لاوكرانيا انا اوكرانيا ستحصل
على كل
قوه
الدفاعات الجويه وكذلك كل المعدات
العسكريه اللازمه من اجل ان تدافع
اوكرانيا عن ارضها
عن المبادئ الاساسيه
وحقوق الانسان والقانون الدولي وقلت هذا
منذ البدايه
وما زلت اكرر ان هذا هو موقفي وسيبقى كما
هو
ساجيبك بان ما شاهدناه حتى الان هو اننا
الحلفاء واتحاد الاوروبي قدمنا لاوكرانيا
سلاح متقدم منذ بدايه الحرب
بضعه ايام من الولايات المتحده
والمانيا وفرنسا بتقديم انواع جديده
بص همم المدرعات
همم
والمركبات القتاليه لاوكرانيا هذه المساله
مهمه جدا هناك همم تشاور متواصل بين دول
التحالف
سنلتقي في رمشتاين وهناك مجموعه اتصال
امريكيه لدعم اوكرانيا
بوزير الدفاع الاوكراني ليحددوا ما هي
الاسلحه التي يحتاجونها ومن هي الدول
الحلفاء الذين سيقدمون سلاح اما بالنسبه
همم
اوروبا قدمنا كل الدفاعات الجويه
والدفاعات ضد الصاروخ التي تفرقا في ساحه
المعركه اليوميه نركز على المنظمات
المستخدمه وهنا لسنا بصدد اضافه المنصات
والمنظمات
بس الاسلحه بل ان تكون هي فاعله وتنجح في
مهمتها ان نضمن ان نقدم معها الذخيره وقطع
الغيار والتدريب والصيانه لكل هذه
المنظومات التي نقدمها وبالتالي من المهم
جدا ان نعرف ما هي المنظومات التي نقدمها
وما هي تبعات ذلك وما تحتاجه هذه المنظمات
هناك همم مجرم وهناك ضحيه وهناك الشعب
الاوكراني وكما قلنا همم ان الدول الاعضاء
تمكنت من ايصال سلاح لاوكرانيا
وقلنا اننا ندعم
الحق
الاوكراني ونحن دائما سنقدم الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا
لانهم شاب يحارب لمستقبلهم والمستقبل دول
اوروبا شكرا جزيلا نعتذر لا نستطيع اخذ
المزيد من الاسئله شكرا